[Music]
Jennifer Garner has officially filed for
divorce from Ben Affleck a source close
to the couple tells et the filing was
only a matter of time it's been nearly
two years since they first announced
their split the timing of this divorce
report is interesting because for a
while now it really seemed that Ben and
Jen have been on a path to
reconciliation they've attended church
together on Sundays they vacationed in
London together they went to even vote
together at election time while how do
you make all that work I mean you guys
got a lot going on madura bus window
fireplace jen and ben first met in two
thousand on the set of the movie Pearl
Harbor chance that you might kind of
sort of know like me in 2005 they tied
the knot and went on to have three
children ten years later in june of 2015
the pair announced they were separating
after it was alleged that Ben had an
affair with their nanny he denied the
cheating rumors in the nearly two years
since the split been continued to
celebrate holidays like halloween and
christmas with his kids i can tell you
that we're going to do skiing in montana
our family and matt damon's family and
my brother's family and should be a lot
of fun Ben and Jen have a die-hard
committed to co-parenting
[Music]
you